Непоганий турник.
[сміється]
♪ Чиї коні у полонинці червоні блукають? ♪
♪ Чи не в мого миленького водички шукають? ♪
♪ Якби знала, що милого, що мого серця, ♪
♪ То я би їх напоїла з нового відерця, ♪
♪ То я би їх напоїла з нової криниці ♪
♪ Та й водички би принесла хоч би й з-за границі. ♪
♪ Ой, біда солоденька, в душу тебе вкладу ♪
♪ За всю журбу забуваю за тебе... ♪
Оце круглий хліб.
Там печеться формовий — квадратний,
а це вже круглий — з найвищого сорту,
має трохи цукру.
І ми його випікаємо, не розкладаючи вогню в печі.
Уже так [печемо].
Раніше ми випікали до ста [буханок].
А тепер випікаємо чотириста [буханок]
чи триста п'ятдесять — як коли.
Щодня.
До хліба треба піднятися вночі о першій годині,
щоб зробити всю витримку хліба,
щоб він був добрий, смачний.
І перед тим, як встаємо до хліба,
вмиваємося, молимося Богу...
[чоловік за кадром] П'ємо каву.
Та просимо Бога,
щоб поміг нам роботу зробити,
а людям щасливо «зужиткувати» —
з'їсти його [хліб].
Особливо треба з душею робити,
бо якщо поганий настрій,
то і хорошого хліба не буде.
Граємо, співаємо. [сміється]
А музика, пісня, додає нам сил.
♪ Гори мої дуже файні, гори з ямочками, ♪
♪ Та й покрию вас, файні гори, всіх співаночками. ♪
♪ Та як буде добра доля, я вас позбираю. ♪
♪ Та як буде лиха доля, всіх позабуваю. ♪
Різні пісні.
Спершу думала, щоб Бог допоміг зробити,
а потім, щоб люди купували,
щоб їм було добре,
щоб ми добре це зробили,
щоб люди ще купували наш хліб.
Та й на санях везла,
бо то було взимку, в лютому,
коли я почала пекти.
Тому на санях тягнула
до магазину чотири кілометри.
У мене є рецепти і свої давні,
яких навчив дід,
але це — мій секрет.
[сміється]
♪ Як я дуже зголодніла, хліба мені, хліба. ♪
♪ Коли ж я підживилася, діда мені, діда. ♪
[сміється]
♪ Коли ж я підживилася хлібом біленьким, ♪
♪ мені уже захотілося хлопця молодого. ♪
[сміється]
— Будеш ти йти?
— Та ні, бо вибирати хліб вже треба!
Але це треба віднести до автобуса,
бо то зараз автобус.
Співати дуже люблю.
Руслана приїжджала до нас,
хотіла мене послухати.
Чотири години співала їй.
Напередодні Майдану
[Революції Гідності].
Син їздив.
А ми не мали часу,
бо і хліб пекти треба було.
Ми дуже багато хліба передавали на Майдан.
Напечемо, в ящики попакуємо,
все скотчем обтягнемо,
і автобусами туди.
Пакуємо хліб, бо дуже погана дорога.
Їхати не дуже хочеться.
То ми просимо водія автобуса,
міцно повністю запаковуємо.
Водій, що хліб забирає, грошей не бере,
а бере хліб,
який ми йому даємо свіженький.
Гарно запаковуємо,
скотчем заліплюємо,
передаємо автобусом, бо нам так легше.
А там люди вже чекають хліб.
Там забирає продавець до магазину.
А з магазину вже продає.
Сьогодні субота.
Автобус завантажений дуже.
Ганусю, запитай та скажи мені,
чи залишати вам на завтра хліб,
бо не буде завтра хліба.
Гаразд.
Вони так біжать забирати все,
що де є у будинках,
бо туристи приїхали, а нема що їсти.
♪ [Василь співає] ♪
Ну ми це клали на вечорниці.
Це згадка про самобутність наших предків.
Як проводили вечори, як працювали.
Колись же не було так близько будинків —
один до іншого,
сусідів не було, як зараз,
були дуже далеко одні від інших.
Прийдуть одні, прийдуть інші:
вишивають ввечері,
одні буришники печуть,
одні хліб печуть...
а про горілку навіть ніхто і не чув,
бо ніхто її не пив.
На колядники,
то десь було 250 грамів горілки.
То ці 250 грамів були і на Різдво,
і на всі три святкові дні.
Якось сюди, до Верховини,
приїхали аргентинці.
Було сто п'ять людей.
Нас запрошували туди співати.
Ми там співали.
Були такі там літні люди,
що їм вже за 80 років.
Коли вони від'їжджали вже,
бо їх годували, приймали там,
то вони нас цілували, і плакали.
Бо вони самі з Ворохти, звідси,
з Гуцульщини: з Косова...
Вони були з онуками, з дітьми своїми.
І казали, що дають 100 000 євро,
щоб Василь мене пустив з ними в Аргентину.
[сміються]
А Василь сказав, що не хоче.
[сміється]
[лунає традиційне гуцульське егокання]
Таке в нас ехо в горах, в полонинах.
Одні до інших люди з гори на гору
могли видавати такі звуки,
щоб знали, що там теж хтось є.
Чи якщо десь хтось заблукав
у полонині в туманну погоду.
[налаштовують музичні інструменти]
Не намагаються зберегти автентику
гуцульського краю:
співи, танці,
одяг, який є на Гуцульщині,
традиції, обряди...
Якщо це все зникне, то можна вважати,
що і нашої нації нема,
що гуцулів нема — гуцули пропали.
Я люблю співати. І хліб.
Одне іншому не заважає.
Я і хліб замішую, і співаю. Разом.
Бо як дуже тяжко на душі,
бо життя не так гладко складається,
як хотілося би:
є і проблеми, по-всякому є,
бо життя є життя,
життя прожити — не поле перейти.
Буває добре, буває погано,
але...
Чуєш пісню, чуєш музику,
то зразу стає трохи на душі веселіше
та й той увесь негатив, що впливає...
Як-от на мене.
То відрада моя — пісня.
Як почну співати, то мені все...
Помолюся Богу і співаю.
В мене оце.
♪ Ой, Господи милосердний, я Богу молюся, ♪
♪ Та я не так за багатство, як за добру долю. ♪
♪ Бо багатство, коли велике, не можеш доробити, ♪
♪ То як маєш добру долю — гарно у світі жити. ♪
На сьогодні роботу завершено.
Буришників напекли, хліба напекли.
Аби тепер Бог допоміг людям весело спожити.